hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast news structure-based drug
design opportunities Virgie for gpcrs
and related transporters presented by
sid Tobel chief scientific officer 3d to
drug corporation I'm Alexis Corrales of
labyrinth and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab routes labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before I
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Topol I would now turn the presentation
over to him good afternoon everybody
first of all I'd like to thank the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
present today to you and the
participants were listening and I hope I
can share with you some very exciting
news reports what I'm going to be
talking about is new structure-based
opportunities for gpcrs and transporters
I'm working with 3d to drug as I was
mentioned we are a company interested in
early discovery opportunities for drugs
based on using structure based method
and were particularly awkward
interested in novel opportunities and
that's why today we're talking about
gpcrs and transporters because in the
past few years there have been a number
of exciting new developments which I'd
like to give you a taste of so first of
all to give some explanation as to why
there has been so much new structure
based on information available
particularly x-ray structures that's due
to a number of new approaches that have
evolved over the past few years that
have made it possible to get structures
for membrane bound proteins particular
gpcrs these tools to a large extent take
care take advantage of a number of
different stabilizing effects to make
the protein more stable and more
amenable to crystallization to get
atomic detail structures and these
include such things as crystallizing the
gpcr with companion proteins which could
be antibodies nano bodies other proteins
that Co crystallize with the GPCR or
modifications that the gpcr which are
also aimed at stabilizing the protein
and these could be mutations to specific
residues which can stabilize the protein
or truncations of for example the end
terminus and C terminus and include such
things as well as Co crystallizing with
high affinity ligands which tend to be
inhibitors for the most part with all of
these modifications there's always a
concern of what I call the you know the
Heisenberg principle that there's a
concern that some of the modifications
may introduce artifacts but I think at
this point most of what we're seeing
we've got confirmation through different
methods that the results we're seeing
now are generally quite reliable and
accurate in terms of structure
information that's coming out
and one more recent approach that's
rapidly gaining interest and success is
cryo-em which is allowing us to get
still more information about GPCRs in a
more rapid pace so to move on why is
this sort of information these atomic
level structures of GPCRs and
membrane-bound proteins so valuable so
is an early example what I'm showing you
here the crystal structure of the first
membrane-bound gpcr bound to a ligand
beta nergic receptor in the lower
left-hand corner of your slide came out
in to late 2007 as an example from our
own work we docked computationally known
ligands into the active site to see how
they might dock known inhibitors and on
the Left I'm showing you timolol and
blue as a docked in as compared to the
x-ray structure the bound ligand Corozal
and then shortly thereafter the exon
x-ray structure came out with timolol
bound shown on the right in yellow and
you can see how well the structure
itself of the timolol bound was
reproduced and this took as you can see
only a few months this was available by
2008 in the same timeframe we also did
an in silico screen where we dock
thousands of ligands thousands of
molecules virtually into the active site
of the protein and the numbers
associated with each of these structures
number 1820 etcetera indicate their
ranking in these few thousand hundreds
of thousands of compounds so for example
number 20 on the upper right carvedilol
a well-known beta blocker with low nano
molar activity came out in the top 20
was the 20th hit ranked hit out of
hundreds of thousands of ligands so this
identifying carvedilol from hundreds of
thousands of ligands in silico took
literally a matter of months till it was
identified test retested and whatnot as
well as these other compounds and it's
the kind of activity that took many many
years to generate in pharmaceutical
companies so it gives an idea of how how
quickly the drug discovery process can
be advanced by virtue of access to these
sorts of structures so what sort of
information are we now seeing in terms
of the structures of the gpcrs what is
it telling us what we're starting from a
bird's eye view to get some general
understanding of these structures and
how they change with bound ligand so
what I'm showing you on the left is a
comparison of the x-ray structure I just
showed you of the beta adrenergic
receptor in the inactive form as well as
overlapping with it in green an active
version of the beta adrenergic receptor
and what we can see is that by comparing
these structures and many others that
there are some changes in the lower
portion of the protein the intracellular
region for example helix six shifts
significantly when the receptor is in
the active form and a number of other
changes we've been able to characterize
and observe in a number of structures
such as the contraction in the upper
region of the protein the orthis there
excite with a ligand binds we've also
been able to examine some other
characteristic features that have been
postulated over time as to what
determines whether or not the protein is
in the active or inactive site so for
example the C wxp toggle switch which
was assumed the tryptophan was assumed
to be something that flips into a
different state it's with different
position when it goes from the
to the inactive form it was then
identified by comparing x-ray structures
that there isn't an exact xual flipping
to just the slight shift in the position
of the endo and a number of other
changes such as the ionic lock the de ry
collection of residues which were form a
salt bridge network which were thought
to be required for in the inactive form
it was found that it isn't an absolute
requirement but it does appear but in
some cases the full network isn't there
and analogous ly a similar network for
the active form isn't always fully in
place so we've seen a lot of general
information that we can start to
characterize what's constitute the act
of an inactive state and we've even seen
intermediate confirmations of partially
active so we're getting some information
now let's look closer at the what's
known as the ortho steric site and
that's where traditionally we've assumed
that most ligands that come into the
protein bind and in the ortho steric
site what we're seeing is if we take a
look at two different proteins in orange
is the x-ray the ligand of the x-ray
structure I just told showed you the
beta adrenergic receptor we see that for
the histamine receptor there's a bound
ligand which is has its ligand much
deeper into the pocket and in the
chemokine receptor x-ray structure we
see the ligand much further up so this
now suggests that the autistic site has
if you will a lower and an upper portion
to it well other structures have
actually complicated or explained
expanded this perspective even further
so if you look at a pure energic
receptor x-ray structure
whose ligand is shown on the left
superimpose with the cannabinoid
receptor with its ligand receptor
complex shown on the right with its
ligand shown in brown we can see that
there's actually room for both of these
ligands to sit in the receptor at the
same time in that so-called ortho steric
region so there seems to be an up and
down in the left and a right side to
this ortho steric region if we look at
closely related receptors such as the
various various opioid receptors one
exciting development in 2012 in a single
nature in nature addition for different
papers came out with four different
x-ray structures of different opioid
receptors and it's thought it's these
structures start to both explain and
amplify some of the things that we've
seen before in terms of looking at how
the SAR of ligands for the opioid
receptors work so for example if we look
on the left side we can see that a
typical opioid receptor cap opioid
receptor inhibitor sits with one portion
overlapping the histamine h1 ligand and
that portion of the ligand is what's
traditionally been thought of as the
message region of the ligand and the
upper left portion sits is characterized
as the address region of the ligand and
sure enough they sit in two slightly
different regions of the ortho steric
site so this shows that in fact there
are regions in the ortho steric side or
in that ortho steric area that
correspond to the message and address
region of the ligands but with newer
structures with further structures
coming out if we now look at all four of
the structures we see that in fact two
of the structures do have the same
address region whereas two of the other
structures have a different address
region so
are these work interest in home address
regions it's not clear but the questions
start to emerge and I'd like to ask you
to keep this in mind as I progress these
nature design these auxilary regions
that man design them that we just
discovered them are they there for
selectivity or are they potential
allosteric sites and in fact if we look
at the same receptor and two different
crystal structures so for example here
we have two chemokine crystal structures
one with a small molecule shown on the
on the top on the left and one with the
peptide ik like a molecule shown on the
right and we see that there's a very
little overlap between those two ligands
in their structures of now we're looking
at the same protein so what is starting
to emerge if we look at the structures
that are coming out is that the so
called what the steric site is not
actually as much a single site as a hub
region where the ligands for the
receptor tend to come in the hub region
has different degrees of openness that
can accommodate different ligands
ranging from large peptides to small
molecules as small as amino acids or if
you include rhodopsin even as small as a
single photon and this hub region has
sub regions which may have different
usages so the next thing I'd like to
draw some attention to is one of the
areas with GPCR is one of the subtleties
that have come to the forefront over the
recent years is how important biases for
GPCRs and by bias I mean that the same
GPCRs can trigger different effectors
and so that they can signal different
events downstream some of which may be
desirable and some of which may be the
adverse effects such as an opioid
there's what you want to tune out
certain effects and just keep the
analgesic effects so one of them may be
resident in for example the g-protein
and others in the in different g-protein
or an arresting so from a perspective
look at where we are with understanding
the signal bias from structure based
information so shown here again in green
is the same beta adrenergic receptor in
the ligand I'm sorry in yes schooling
and is shown in orange corozal all that
I showed you earlier but superimposed
here is a crystal structure with
carvedilol now cavity Lal is a biased
agonist that Simeon stimulates g-protein
independent signaling and what we can
see on the one hand is that it interacts
with different HeLa C's then the
carvedilol interacts with different
portions of the receptor then does
Cara's law but on the other hand we
don't see an overall change instructor
an obvious change in structure that
would explain why one of these causes
signal bias and not the other the signal
bias is expected to take place closer to
the intracellular region and we do see
some hints of differences in structures
that reflects seing that could reflect
single bias in this example we're
showing here from crystal structures by
Cruz at all where we see that two
different
Muir set muscarinic receptors M 2 and M
3 which have different signal bias M 2
biased towards GI 0 and M 3 2 GQ 11 we
see that they have different structures
in the region interns in transmembrane
helix 5 in the very region that would be
interacting with the effectors either
the g-protein or the effect so have we
been able
this youth structure-based design to
actually obtain and by we I mean the
general public have we been has there
been efforts to get by his compounds
from this information so a number of not
too long ago Mike mangly get out on
co-workers as an example shown here took
the MU opioid receptor an x-ray
structure of that in the inactive form
docked again in silico three million
molecules into the u mu opioid receptor
and from that extracted some of the most
in the top among the top interesting
hits and found hits which did have high
GI zero and minimal beta arresting
activity and then optimize that compound
and then using that compound screened it
against a screen of three hundred and
sixteen gpcrs and in fact were able to
confirm that it was selectively against
a new opioid receptor with no cap or
knots acceptance of their activity but I
just want to point out to you that this
was done first of all with an inactive
form of the x-ray struck structure and
yet what was identified was an active
form so it does this is a common
occurrence and the other thing is that
uh what it really took to get the silly
bias is the testing in the screen so it
was a major effort but it's still not
trivial to get the bias by design so we
are getting x-ray structure information
about possible differences between
binding of ligands in the active site D
what the steric side and from the
computational side there are studies
which I won't present here which are
elaborating on dynamics of how
signals might propagate from the ortho
spheric site where ligand binds down to
the intracellular region where the
receptor it where the effector is but
all in all to be able to rationally and
design through computational methods
signal bias is still a very challenging
thing uh if I can I'd like to make a
brief digression now and talk a little
bit about transporters for endogenous
amines a common or risks as a common
class of ligands for GPCRs such as 5-ht
dopamine so these are the transporters
are if you way away you can think of
them as nature's allosteric sites or one
of the advantages that are motivate
people to look for allosteric ligands is
that allosteric sites on proteins is
that if you can modulate an allosteric
site then you rather than directly
activate the protein that you don't have
to worry about introducing an agonist
with higher activity than the natural
agonist you're only going to modulate it
to enhance the activity of the natural
agonist and similarly if you block the
egress of ARAG and s by blocking the
transporter that removes the agonist
you're achieving the same effect so ah
again transporters and serotonin
transporter is a an important example of
another class of drug related class of
drugs and it's a bit of interest for
quite some years and until about ten
years ago there were no structures for
transporters in about 2005 to seven an
x-ray structure appeared for a bacterial
homologue of the endogenous transporters
that was for the leucine transporter and
it showed
that the ligand leucine was bound in the
center of the protein which is also a
transmembrane protein and we were
interested in seeing how actually the
ligand leucine gets to that site and
when we discovered upon doing various
simulations and docking using glide from
shore danger is that there is stopover
sites as the ligand gets towards this
and one in particular was immediately
above the core site and and around that
same time period another x-ray structure
of the loosing transporter became
available and this with the tricyclic
antidepressant clomipramine bound to it
and what was observed is that the site
at which that ligand bound actually
overlapped not with the central binding
site of leucine but with these one of
these stopover sites that we had just
described so the question is why is that
there is there really a site there are
these stopover sites supposed to be
there and at this point I want to point
out that escitalopram which is a lexapro
and important tri SSRI compound is known
to be an allosteric modifier of its own
activity so that suggests that
escitalopram
itself has an allosteric site in
serotonin transporter so the question is
does the serotonin transporter also have
allosteric sites like this is this the
same site and on these vestibule site
there for a reason fast forward to 2006
and the next 16 and an x-ray structure
has now x-ray structures appear with the
serotonin human serotonin transporter
and indeed as you see in brown
the center there's a escitalopram bound
in the center of the 5 HD transporter
and corresponding to the course I
described earlier but there's also
another molecule of escitalopram bound
in this vestibule and that corresponds
to the same site we were talking about
before in losing transporter and sure
enough if we do similar calculations of
simulating the progression of 5-ht the
natural substrate for the serotonin
transporter through here we do find that
it has stopover sites in similar regions
and it also finds that these two sites
we're talking about until now how useful
is this sort of information well for
drug discovery uh we used this recent
serotonin transporter structure to
assess some SAR of citalopram analogs we
looked at various different regions of
the modifications of various different
regions of the escitalopram shown in the
upper right hand corner and in
particular I want to show one example
here where we change the cyano group
circled in red here to this alkyl
function and we examine the SAR both in
the core site as one and the stopover
site as two and most of the other
compounds we analyzed we were able to
fairly well rationalize the SAR but for
this one if we looked at it in the core
site as one it's a jar docking suggested
that it talks fairly well and similarly
if our docking suggests that a fairly
nice binding site in the s2 site and yet
the SAR suggested that there is no
binding in the s2 site and if we compare
these two or look at them superimpose we
can see here within the circled in red
why that's the case if the two of them
were bound together they would actually
clash with each other
but again this is useful information not
just in explaining the SAR of this
compound but in providing provocative
hints as to how one can for example link
these molecules so returning now to
GPCRs are in about 2012 and in the area
of muscarinic GPCRs crews and co-workers
examined an x-ray structure for the
muscarinic receptor the m3 and noticed
that there was a vestibule sitting over
the binding site shown on the left in
this red circle with the binding site
peeping out in green of the of the
ligand and what we are Taiyo trope IAM
and they speculated that that might be a
stopover site and they did molecular
dynamic simulations and did find in fact
the shown on the right that the ligand
does stop there through computational
simulations well shortly thereafter an
x-ray structure appears with the AH
crystal structure the m2 in the active
form and sure enough there's a ligand
bound I Arak so in the central in the
normal or hysteric site and another
ligand bound in this vestibule up here
and this is an active form and other
things that were observed is that
there's a contraction of the active site
with just AI peroxo bound in it relative
to the antagonist which is consistent
with other x-ray structures but that
contraction is enhanced when we have the
allosteric ligand in the upper site so
this is all suggesting that this as well
as the hallmark helix 6 at the bottom
change are all interacting
synergistically with each other so as
another example not just two sides but
as in three different x-ray structures
of protease activated receptor to three
different sites have now been found for
ligands in the protease activate someone
in PA are part two one near this we're
shown here or if you will marked by the
antibody in green in the upper right
hand corner and an allosteric site
allosteric one ah and the another
allosteric site which is pretty much on
the outside left allosteric sue so there
are three different sites seen on this
receptor so inside the GPC are in the
transmembrane how deep can you go and
find sites well one clue came from a
high-resolution x-ray structure of the
adenosine a2 receptor where it was
observed that there was a water network
and in one region of this water network
there's a sodium water cluster and this
cluster in does the kinking in helix six
and seven which it would which would
prevent the activation conformation of
the protein and so it was suggested that
this could be a site and for something
like Amelia riding computational studies
in fact supported that well and turns
out then that CRF to for example the
corticotropin releasing factor protein
was found with the ligand bound actually
very deep below the endogenous site ah
the UH on the upper and the upper circle
in red is where the endogenous ligand
would be expected to be and the ligand
found in the x-ray structure six far
deeper into that and overlaps with the
sodium site that we were just discussing
and even deeper than that chemokine
receptors for C structures have come out
for CC r2 and C
zr9 with Liggins bound even deeper so on
the left side here we see on the on the
very bottom CCR to our a is a ligand
bound at the very bottom of the
chemokine receptor and this suggests
that it's directly interacting with the
effector so whereas we tend to think of
the office there excite as the important
site we see that here this BMS 681 in
the top of the chemo counter sector
actually is more indirectly influenced
g-protein biting whereas the lower
ligand is all the way down at the bottom
and can directly block inhibitory
protein binding and in a really
surprising case shown in the lower lower
right 82 engine tension receptor we see
that the protein itself angiotensin ii
receptors helix 8 which is normally in
the position where the right hand circle
is shown in the beta-2 adrenergic
receptor shifts all the way to a
different location which was block
interaction of the protein with its
effector and this surprising shift shows
that the protein itself has a component
blocking its interaction with the
effector and this explains why this
protein is has been so difficult to
activate to find active ligands for what
about binding on to and outside and
through the receptor we've seen examples
of that as well in the pure nergic
receptor p2y 1 we find the ligand VP tu
sitting completely as shown here on the
green sticks completely outside the
protein so we're suggesting we're seeing
that you can modify the activity of a
GPCR with the ligand sitting totally
outside of the protein so is this this
goes against what we normally are used
to think about things but is it really
actually plus
that this can happen well we know for
example that lipids caressed work
cholesterol and other things
modified dimerization and dimerization
does play a role has been reported a
number of different cases it does play a
role in activation of various GPCRs both
hetero and Homer dive homo divers Asians
so external modification modulation is
very reasonable antibodies and nano
bodies have been used to manipulate the
state of a protein for example to induce
the active state so this is very
plausible what we're seeing and in fact
the proof is in the pudding
as another example in the appellant
receptor an x-ray structure was found
where the pet where peptide analog of a
pail and sits both inside the receptor
at nearly in the orthostatic region the
lower red circle and then comes out in
the round and on the outside of the
receptor so it's sitting inside and
outside the receptor at one ligand at
the same time and as a different example
of sitting inside and outside the
receptor in the GPR protein there's an
x-ray structure which shows a leg intact
875 which goes through the receptor from
sits partially outside and goes through
the trans membrane into the inside so
rather than wrap around like a pail and
it actually traverses so what we're
seeing in effect and here's just a
number of these different x-ray
structures structures of ligands
superimposed on one x-ray structure of a
protein is that there are many different
sites for modulating the protein so if
you're a authors there excite at this
point in time you're probably wondering
about getting your resume together cuz
you're not as unique as you might have
once thought what is some of the things
besides modular
that could be done with some of these
sites from a drug discovery point of
view is that some of these sites can
potentially be used to link together to
form by topic Liggins and there are
people working on this sort of
approaches for both GPCRs and
transporters as indicated in some of the
references at the bottom here so is this
way of looking at what's going on in
GPCRs does this actually make sense it
sort of takes the emphasis away from the
ortho steric side well if you look on
the left-hand side of your general
enzyme then on the bottom the way we've
shown it here where you have the active
site that's where the action is that's
the important part of the reason that
the enzyme exists for example and the
allosteric site where you will modulate
it from a distance on top is far removed
from the critical region if you look at
a GPCR on the right-hand side you might
consider that the active site is where
the effector is engaged because that's
the purpose of the GPCR and the author
steric site is really allosteric or
distal from where the action is so this
kind of rethinking of what North the
steric site is is rather rather
reasonable than specially in slide of
the information we've seen recently I've
been talking mostly till now about class
a gpcrs and I want to discuss a little
bit about class the non class a gpcrs so
here for example I'm showing on the top
a schematic of a Class C GPCR Class C
GPCRs have not just a seven
transmembrane region as shown in green
in the cartoon on top but two other
extracellular region regions of Venus
flytrap
region shown in blue and the
cysteine-rich linker region and squiggly
lines
and the way this works the way the
receptor is known to be activated is
that when the ortho steric ligand which
in this case binds that this Venus
flytrap glutamate in the case of MU R
this structure closes and if and whereas
an inhibitor would lock the Venus
flytrap into the open position and
that's shown on the bottom and
representations of an active and
inactive crystal structure of the Venus
flytrap
and you'll notice while on the
right-hand side of each of these
structures there's a closing and opening
of where the ligand bound on the
backside of the protein there's an
opening and closing the reverse
direction the opposite effect happens on
the backside so this suggests on the
lower left of your screen that if you
can plug up something in there into
where this opening takes place in the
active you could potentially find an
allosteric ligand on the extracellular
side and we I just want to point out
that this opens up a concept that I
think we can bring forward into seven
transmembrane proteins is that not only
finding new sites but possibly creating
and designing new sites so I just want
to say quickly that we did do something
like this where we look for you did some
screening did some docking and then
screen some compounds and did find some
initial activity using this approach so
it may actually be possible to find new
or the stearic sites what about the
transmembrane now since that time x-ray
structures have started to appear for
the transmembrane regions of the Class C
and Class F gpcrs
and here side-by-side are as an example
of an N glorified Class C GPCR and on
the right smooth in the class F gpcr and
if you notice the structure of the
ligands in both cases and stick-figure
actually overlap with the sodium water
site that we described earlier for the
adenosine receptor so this suggests that
you can in fact use this site that we
have found man has found ligands binding
at this site although not realizing it
at the time to modulate these proteins
an obvious core a question one can ask
is that whether or not you can really
modulate the protein here as the active
site the ortho steric site for example
of an M glue R is the Venus flytrap
which sits in the extracellular region
well in fact a very intriguing
experiment was done a number of years
ago where and the M glue r5 receptor was
truncated the entire extracellular
region was removed and what was found is
what had been an allosteric modulator a
Pam acting in the transmembrane region
with the full protein now became an
agonist so this demonstrates that the
seven transmembrane region alone can be
a fully functional activator of its
effector uh so at least for this example
for M glue are five of the Class C
protein and suggest that you can operate
without the extracellular region ah how
useful is this kind of structural
information here well just to give a
couple of examples from our own work one
of the more interesting compounds in n
gu r 5 has been m pep shown here in
yellow ball and stick
it's a tiny molecule and yet extremely
efficient a strong
am potent them and it's extreme
efficiency has been somewhat baffling
for many years but when we dock it into
the x-ray structure without going
through the details
it forms nice hydrogen bonds a nice band
it's packed in very exquisitely into the
active site which explains how this high
affinity is there and another intriguing
question that has been plaguing the
field is why such small differences
exist between names which are allosteric
deactivators of Clem GU or five and
Pam's
which are activators and yet small
differences on the right hand side of
each of these molecules at the box you
can see just changing from a tri
cyclopropyl to a cyclo penta chess which
is something from an and to a Pam and in
fact when we dot these structures into
the x-ray structure we find that these
slight differences in the ligand
structure cause a protrusion next to
HeLa C's 3 5 6 & 7 which are the very
HeLa C's which are known to be
responsible at the intracellular region
for activating or deactivating are going
from the active to the inactive state so
these do suggest that the same sorts of
principles in terms of how the G protein
changes structure when going from the
active to the interest inactive state in
the intracellular region could be are
probably manifest in Class C and and as
we now believe in the other class
receptors and as another example now
coming back to the smoothing receptor
class F receptor the smooth intercept
was actually the first demonstration of
a non clay a full extra x-ray structure
wrote full
gpcr for a non clase GPCR and what was
seen is that in fact there can be two
ligands two binding sites one in the
cysteine-rich extracellular domain uh
where there's a cholesterol could be
mound and in the transmembrane region
such as this motor Gibb with a ligand
bound there so there were two potential
sites um so this was the first
full-length uh one interesting thing is
that we were with those structures we
were able to see now what the residues
are they're responsible for resistance
in this ah
and then this system but the interesting
thing that came from looking at the
structures is actually feedback from
when ligands bind to the transmembrane
region it causes a differential
interaction with the extracellular
region so in contrast to the way I said
earlier that there's evidence with Class
C receptors that you can have
transmembrane only modulation it looks
like you can have that there's certain
times clear interaction going up from
the transmembrane to the extracellular
and finally just a few words about Class
B gpcrs and information that's available
for them so here and this slide what I
show is an example of two different
chemo class chemical classes of ligands
bound now at the lower end of the
transmembrane seven transmembrane region
at the outer side again of the receptor
and in both cases this the locations of
these names suggest that they are wedged
in such a way that they preclude the
entity in the helix 6 from moving into
its position that would cause the
protein to be in the active
or so we are finding ligands that bind
very close to the where the action is
the effector and control the proteins
interaction with its effector there's
also been some computational studies on
Pam's activators near there and it's
suggested that they may bind close to
this region in such a way as to induce
the change in conformation of helix six
that would activate the protein and then
as a final example for the Class B gpcr
glp-1 receptor has now been solved with
using cryo-em
technology and the full structure shows
a fascinating interaction between all
the components not just the g protein
which is coupled here and shown in the
bottom in blue but we see that the
ligand are glp-1 is changes its
structure in the context of the fully
activated protein in that it extends
down into the seven transmembrane
regions shown in orange that the seven
transmembrane region moves up slightly
reaches up and the extracellular portion
shown in orange along the ligand and
into the region of the extracellular
part of the protein so all three are
interacting with each other and it shows
that it's a it could be a very complex
and intriguing activation process to
understand and to modulate in terms of
drug design so ah in wrapping up what I
liked us as far as the Kanaan class-a
receptors so for non class-a receptors
the author the endogenous site is either
in the extracellular region or includes
the extracellular Ridge
because they have this additional
n-terminal domain but it is also
possible for as we've seen numerous
cases of to make and non endogenous
ligands that are bound in the seven
transmembrane region only these are what
I like to call man-made sites ah and
many of these till now have been
man-made by accident people have
designed compounds but not happy until
recently the availability of the
structures to do that and we're also
seeing that there is a potential
interplay an important interplay between
the different portions of the protein
and finally in terms of structure
function perspectives on all of these
sites in terms of our view and
understanding of GPCRs and transporters
and how these GPCR works it seems like
the key areas there's a extracellular
and then an intracellular end and the
ligands generally come in at the
extracellular and some to send the
message down to the intracellular so
these are the key signaling regions of
incoming and outgoing so those are the
most important connections so the GPC
ours if you will are actually to some
extent acting like what I sometimes call
chopsticks holding on to one end and
controlling what's going on at the other
end but clearly that clearly that these
structures can be modified at along a
number of different pressure points in
between the upper and lower end some of
these new pressure points we're
discovering we've discovered them
accidentally because we've designed
compounds through in vitro or other
screens and now are finding where they
actually
by so this is offering a whole spectrum
of other sites where we can now
rationally design compounds for GPCRs
for example and what I think is
particularly exciting is to now look at
all these structures and go beyond the
ones that are appearing in published
reports and try to find entirely new
sites where ligands can be predicted to
bind and use those to potentially design
new compounds with new properties and
potentially advantageous therapeutic
effect and then I would like to just
close by acknowledging some my
collaborators for the most recent work
that I've been included in this paper in
this presentation so Mike Savio and a
lot of Li and glue are work that was
cited more recently in this paper work
and for the transporters colleagues at
Lynn Beck Research in Copenhagen and
also the University of Copenhagen
the modeling that I cited here that
we've done has been with Schrodinger
using glide than other utilities and to
get a documentation of many of the
things that I've talked about here or a
fairly recent one I highly recommend and
just recently published book edited by
Alex hydrates on computational methods
for GPCR drug discovery and with that
again I'd like to thank you for your
attention and I'd like to again thank
the organizers for allowing me to make
this presentation today thank you doctor
Tokyo for that informative presentation
we are live Q&A portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question drop down box located on the
far
left of your presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click the send button
will insert as many questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is how would one look for new
sites uh well that's obviously an
intriguing question for us as I was just
saying so one is the simple approach
which I often find works rather well or
very fond of it's actually inspect the
protein and look for other sites by
inspection oftentimes just looking at a
surface rendition of the protein for
example there are computational tools
which can a for example use
Schrodinger's site find there is a tool
which will actually probe the surface of
a protein look for new sites we can look
for new sites on protein a by looking at
newly identified sites on protein B and
seeing if similar sites are available on
protein a so if you will looking to see
if we can transfer sites from one
protein to another we can try another
approach is to take advantage of things
like designing they were very covalently
bound ligands that's been very
successful in other areas and by looking
at available cystines covalently binding
a ligand and then optimizing for
perceived pocket until one gets to a non
covalently bound ligand and fragment
base design which is also a possibility
for identifying new sites our next
question is were these new sites
anticipated uh well yes and no I mean of
course nobody knows that everybody's
thinking but
there were some allusions to it for
example there for many years long before
this kind of structural information was
available only rhodopsin structure was
available there had been simulations
suggesting that retinal enters from the
side of the protein from the side of the
transmembrane rather through coming in
through the extracellular region so in a
way that was a precursor to it
um but certainly many of the examples
like in the chemokine receptors with
ligands that were found at the very
intracellular bottom of the receptor
some of these were thought were were
really believed to be binding in the
orthostatic region so there certainly
were surprised some of might have been
expected but for the most part there
have been the number of surprises our
next question is can homology modeling
fill in the gaps for structures that are
not yet available uh yes yes and no it
depends a lot on the questions you're
asking
so homology modeling if you have closely
related proteins and if you're looking
at the same state then you can do
extremely well in terms of identifying
what regions what sorts of interactions
might be nearby in other words are there
hydrophobic residues in the region is
there a potential that is what's a
pocket in one region is now blocked by
another residue so in that respect that
can do very well if you have a close
enough template where homology models
and an orphan even times x-ray
structures from not from slightly
distant proteins of different states of
a problem is in the fine tuning of the
results so if you're getting if you want
to make a comp
found and you're worried about getting
the distance exactly right which you
often are you need to be accurate with
the few within a few tenths of an
angstrom and it's challenging to get a
homology model is that accurate so you
can get good information but x-ray
structures or detailed structural
information is valuable and that's true
even when you already have an x-ray
structure each compound has the
potential for inducing slight changes
when it's complex for the protein our
transporter structures as far along as
those four GPCRs and to my knowledge
they seem to be lagging there hasn't
been as much effort and as much interest
they're seen certainly for some of the
important ones like endogenous amine
transporters very few labs seem to be
working on it and it seems like there's
room for some very important
transporters to be both identified
isolated and structures determined I
mean cannabinoid receptor for example
there's been suggestions or evidence
that the cannabinoid transporters exist
but will seem to be away from actually
having an antenna structure or even
isolation of the protein and it looks
like we have time for one more question
how would one prioritize the possible
sites for targeting drugs oh well I
don't know that it can be done uniformly
I think on a case-by-case basis um in
terms of the priorities for example if
you're in terms of looking at these new
sites that were that
now emerging from the way we've
described I've described it here for
what's in the literature since compounds
at the interests near the intracellular
region are potentially more effective
because they can potentially more
directly modulate or inhibit binding to
an effector and effector but by the same
token they could have the disadvantage
of having less selectivity since there
are fewer effectors there is less
variability in the effector region of
protein so ah it really depends on the
particular case and tell how other
proteins in the class or nearby classes
ah the information you have about how
similar different they are would be an
important characteristic as well as
looking for how amenable they are I mean
we've looked at proteins where new sites
have been identified on one protein but
by virtue of the sequence they're not
available on another protein so I think
you have to evaluate some of these
factors in determining which site to
look at for a particular case I would
like to once again thank dr. Tapia for
his presentation I would also like to
thank elaborate for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2018
you will receive an email from
laboratory play please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye